hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
back I'm foreigner and today we're gonna
be talking about Shaolin in Theon
Daisley moveset that got released around
today at around 3 to 4 p.m. and I will
not be showing the images on screen
during the video as afraid of I am
obviously afraid of copyright so I'm
going to be having a link in the
description to a reddit post that has
the the images I'm currently looking at
right now and we're gonna go over some
of them as well as their feats and then
we're gonna discuss at the end I will
leave a timestamp in the description for
the two characters if you want to see a
specific one yourself if you care about
one more than the other with that like
to be if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new I cover the informational
side of Warner that being leaks balance
changes hero updates all that new type
of stuff new info coming to the game and
with that let's get started
so first off is Shaolin aka the bo staff
guy if you don't know his name see he
seems to have a second stance called the
key or Chi I don't know which one's
going to pronounce I'm gonna be calling
a key for the rest of the video you can
get into key stance by simply holding
the light attack button after performing
a light attack or holding the heavy
button after performing a heavy attack
you must keep the button holdin on to
stay in two key stands you know have to
connect the hit you can simply lift the
attack and transition right into key
stance if you want to we'll get into
some of those moves later but he does
have three chains and infinite combo
alternated from lights and heavies a
triple like combo all going from the
left guard stance and a triple light
combo also going from the right guard
stance he also has a knot in guard
stance mode which could possibly be
something similar to conch shoulder bash
because it is an exponent and I believe
it knocks the opponent on the ground so
it could be something similar to that he
also has a move where he backs up and
does a light attack as well this is
probably from when you're at medium
range just trying to get a quick jab and
poke at the opponent his another move is
a dash forward and side - heavies and he
also has a deflect move that can go
right into key stand so he might be the
assassin of the group judging from that
in key stand Shaolin has a few moves one
being a simple top light and the other
being a side light the top light will
stun the opponent if landed he also has
a top-heavy unblockable in the key
stance and a side heavy from key stance
as well in key stance you can also press
guard break to do a kick and then after
the kick you could follow up with a
light and unblockable heavy or another
kick which is known as a sweep in terms
of feats there isn't really much shown
only the first four but to summarize one
of them is a trap that reveals an
enemy's position kind of similar to a
UAV in Call of Duty but with only in
that area another is where he dashes
behind the enemy and kicks the head
them in the head probably stunning them
and allowing you to go further into your
moveset and get in some combos third is
a feat that heals nearby opponents when
more hits are landed in key stance and
then lastly is the ability to teleport
to any ally around you I'm assuming this
is within a close range not like across
the map that I feel like to be a little
bit unbalanced as always let me know
your thoughts on Shaolin and but next up
we now have T on D or the guy who holds
his sword with one hand T on D has four
chain combos light light light heavy
heavy heavy and heavy light so very
standard combo is really not that hard
to learn he also has a dash forward and
side dash lights and heavies in any
direction he also has two moves called
palm strike and palm strike combo palm
strike is just moving backwards and
pressing guard break but the palm strike
combo is a little bit different it's
still the normal backwards and guard
break to perform the palm strike but you
can also follow that up with a light
attack or heavy attack which is probably
going to be guaranteed it says on the
side toward the index of his character
it says any basic light or a tiger dodge
attack which is the forward or side dash
lights can be combo into palm strike and
then any heavy attack or dragon dodge
which is the forward inside - heavies
can become loaded into dragon kick and
that dragon kick can be cancelled by
either dodging or doing a dodge attack
allowing for some really cool mix ups
and for his feats the first one is a
pulse that boosts his damage every five
seconds when certain conditions are met
no clear what those positions are just
yet another sacrifice is 25% of your
health bar so you can give 15 health
full stamina and it cleanse debuff to
everyone around you probably really good
for a teamfight the third is a healing
buff I'm assuming which gives you
healing when you're below 50 HP and even
more health if you have a bar or lower
and your health bar and lastly T&E can
gain a shield when going into critical
health and the cooldown timer does not
start back up again until you're back at
100 HP
as to probably avoid unbalanced issues
as always give me your thoughts on tea
on day in the comments below I'd love to
know your thoughts just based off the
move set I listed in the feats but for
my general thoughts T on Days feat to me
can look like a tank and shaolin's are
very quick and seem a little bit crazy
in my opinion especially the teleporting
to players and T on DS moveset seems a
little bit less complex to shaolin's but
probably has a lot more damage potential
than shaolin's as well but that guy is
going to be the end of the video
hopefully we'll see a lot more of this
in the upcoming Thursday when they show
off the game place for some of these
characters and maybe they'll show off
the move sets for the other two
characters
well both with that being said guys like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new like I said in the beginning
of the video I covered the leaks the
informational side of foreign or balance
changes hero updates patch notes news
all that type of coverage I like to do
on for honor my two most recent videos
will be on screen if you guys want to
check that out with that guys hope ever
greatest your day think of watching the
video peace out